it would be great if no one broke the
law Roby Greg right if everyone
understood their constitutional rights
and appropriate interaction with police
officers it would be great if people
waited an hour for evidence it would be
great if Alon Omar didn't tweet out
2-year old videos to stoke the flames of
racial hatred but that's not the world
that we live in and so the best that we
can do at this point is get to the truth
and that requires waiting just a minute
my question of the day to all of you is
have you notice a lot of the stories
about the police treating protesters
unfairly just like black lives matter I
think we had to remove that because it
was considered offensive oh really from
YouTube with the whole Vox apocalypse
purge a while back but it's available of
course for people who are watching
exclusively at lot of credit like um
slush mug Club on theblaze
but do you notice that they turn if you
just wait a little bit for the evidence
they usually turn out to be false hmm
and also let's say that's not the case
let's say there wasn't a straight track
record of that uh it still is prudent to
wait a little bit and again just like
the idea of black lives matter hands up
don't shoot was hands were down he was
reaching for the thing that shoots the
cops gun that's just so it was
predicated on a lie the truth matters
when you're going to try and take a
human interest story which of course I
think I think it's effective and it
should be people should care about human
beings we should love one another and
love other human beings but then to
obfuscate the actual data which we've
addressed the data but now I want to get
into specifically with these black lives
matter protesters a lot of the most
viral clips or the hashtag justice for
insert lie here so let's go through the
top five examples of I guess initial
clips so many that or initial clips or
claims that then when you provide
context sort of change and put them in a
different different light so the first
one that comes to mind is uh this there
was a man who was hit by a car and
people were calling for the head I don't
remember his name specifically because
it was a white guy so no one really
cares now they just wanted us do it
because he hit a pro he hit her
protester which at first that sounds
terrible sounds bad and the guy has all
the tattoos so he's he's like straight
from central casting to be someone you
want to have but central casting facts
do not make
yeah ah let's remember this just to
refresh your memory see what they go do
it but he just hit innocent black man no
I don't know a whole lot about this
backstory but as a general rule for
personal protection if you don't want to
be accused of being white supremacist
don't shave your heads and do a white
go-to you don't put on the TSA not
saying that makes you guilty yeah but it
doesn't help so here's the truth about
this because people were immediately
saying this man needs to be put in
custody why isn't this man being treated
brutally by police officers let's assume
for a second that he actually did hit a
protester maybe deliberately let's
assume that this is a guy who there's a
difference between a lot of people say
white crime these people commit crimes
that are far worse why do they get
minimum security prisons well there's a
difference between violent crime or a
crime that is immediate threat to the
officer and something that isn't I can
arrest a Bernie Madoff and not worry
about it turning into rape in the shower
that's also why you can put people in a
minimum-security resort and not worry
about it turning into rape in the shower
so the truth here is that the protester
was hit while walking out into the
middle of traffic multiple witnesses
again before the jury pool was tainted
said that the driver tried to swerve and
avoid him and the driver was going the
speed limit and wasn't intoxicated so
what does that tell you right away okay
speed limit obeying it they did it they
did a breathalyzer or some kind of
toxicology test yeah and then they right
away went to eyewitnesses and many of
them are corroborated yeah now that
doesn't that that matters because one is
a horrible violent crime that is
inspired by hatred and one is an
accident because somebody else was
breaking the law in walking through the
middle of traffic and [ __ ]
unfortunately horribly a tragedy
occurred in that
we said these riots won't help please
stop yeah here's another one this was
the biggest one for a couple of days
then it went away hey by the way let's
not let these go away just like
impeachment no I want that election just
like COBIT no I want that election just
like hands up don't shoot I want you to
bring it back up I want anyone who makes
that claim to be put on display for the
public to argue the truth
chorong games remember we got all kinds
of flack we got temporary suspended on
Instagram she was holding a shotgun and
using her childish human shield you
can't hear the name corn Gaines anymore
James chair Locke will be one of those
right now this was the first headline it
was a white bar owner in Omaha shot and
killed a black protester and he wouldn't
face any charges they said that his dad
owned the bar that he was screaming the
n-word that he basically went out and
hunted a black person and the problem
with this especially when it's not true
is you were creating a false narrative
that it's black versus white or that
white people have had a secret meeting
when we would be okay with some other
white guy going out and shooting an
innocent black civilian solely based on
race I don't know maybe it's because I
choose an association carefully aside
from Trumbo over here I do not know a
single white person who would be okay
with that no well thankfully there's
security camera footage and it turns out
the man in question the man who shot
James Scurlock had actually been mounted
and pummeled into the concrete twice
Scurlock the man who was shot was the
second person after the first two guys
who were pummeling him were scared off
with a warning shot here's the clip
shortly after this point two people jump
on the bar owners back there's a
struggle in the street
Jake garden supporters - shots - shot 7
seconds later James Spurlock jumps on
the back of the bar ona they wrestle in
the street Wow listen the guy fired
warning shots for the first two three
strikes you're shot yeah yeah and we
hate that somebody had you know died for
this but when you attack somebody
especially in a mob situation Steven you
were in a mob situation where you got
attacked before like sure your head is
on survival your head is oh my god I
have no idea where the next attack is
coming from yeah somebody jumps on his
back what the first thing he's gonna do
is like I got to protect myself there
could be three more coming let me be
really clear here
I'm not said that in this specific
instance someone was shot I'm sad of the
actions that took us here from our
leaders yeah I don't think that there's
a I'm actually happy that the man who
was being pummeled for the second time
was able to defend his life in limb I am
too yeah but I'm really sad that
contrary to the opinions of people like
ourselves said please stop these riots
going on we need law and order this is
going to result in more deaths across
the board nobody listened and not a peep
about these protests because they
weren't people actually demanding they
can open up their businesses as with
kovat 19 remember that was the thing
number three in all of these and I want
you to let me know of ones that maybe
I've missed it's really hard to pick
them out there's so many um this was
another another white man and people
when we get that crit that I don't want
to say critic art critic in Dallas the
Vandal and galavant yes why would you
read a report why do they say black man
and I don't say white guy I don't know
about you I've all I've always seen in
these last few if it's on what even if
the white guy who's innocent like white
man defends life by shooting black
looter even when it's like an Asian or a
Hispanic person they say white man now
just to kind of lump it all for shadow
oh sorry I didn't see that man you're
too busy reading the Communist Manifesto
[Laughter]
interesting history this was a white man
who supposedly the first story that you
heard was drove into protesters jumped
out and then shot someone who's a clip
[Music]
remember this was the number-one trend
in this
[Music]
so um Wow and obviously listen what
happens there is that is a tragedy in
the sense it's it's an unfortunate
situation than could have been avoided
at so many points in this timeline that
to me is the greatest tragedy yeah there
were so many points to stop rioting and
looting and some kind of an insurrection
from people trying to defend their
neighborhoods and by the way if the left
had their way now with complete
disbanding of the police then you end up
with vigilante justice I'm saying the
same thing now don't do this Minneapolis
you're going to see more violence I
don't want to see more lives lost black
white red yellow I don't care can we say
red sorry black Oh yellow first nations
of a white guy who shot who ran over the
protest in the shelling of the car
turns out the white man in question was
Nikolas for land that I wasn't
intentionally stepping on a Jew no I
know but now he claimed that he wasn't
familiar with the area that he got stuck
going the wrong way down a one-way
street and then according to witnesses a
protest reached in the window and tried
to grab his gun and got shot now he is
being held on charges of first-degree
assault
which you know this is where it's
difficult if you don't actually have
evidence at that point you are going on
eyewitness testimony and unfortunately
because at this point people think the
end just uh the means just at the end
justify the means
yeah that all I witnessed they're not
going to tell the truth a lot of these
people how do you get some people going
he yelled the n-word and the other five
people say no he didn't know how do you
get one person in five people saying he
reached for his gun the one person
saying no he just went out and ran them
over and he was waving the confederate
flag it said well one of these is not
like the other and truth matters and
that's the real problem here with this
um I I hate say us-versus-them tribalism
because that's something the defense
sitting centrists often use and I don't
mean in a sense that you shouldn't pick
a set of values to adhere to but in this
case if you are being questioned by a
cop your first duty it is a requirement
under the law is to tell the truth by
the way hit the notification bell hit
all notifications if you are watching on
the YouTube because subscriptions don't
mean a whole lot you can subscribe to
the audio podcast and please do consider
supporting joining at ladders credit com
slash mug club you get this wonderful
mug eighty percent more content of
course the entire blaze catalog myth
number four this is another one number
four
I remember this one that an NYPD officer
that shot unarmed an unarmed 13-year old
19 times right this was something that
we also read what's the truth and this
comes from NBC New York who's actually a
34 year old armed gunman who had just
shot someone
Wow yeah you could say that's different
now I know some people say well you only
believe in the cop report well hold on a
second
me thinks that the person who was shot
or witnesses have something to say there
was also ballistic testing oh so it's
more than you know just 45 you right
number five and this one even surprised
me because Elon omar tweeted out this
video and I want to be clear about this
the context really matters here because
there are two layers of Lies this was an
example tweeted out by Ilan Omar just I
think two three days ago I think it
might have been June 5th and everyone
saw this this trended of course thanks
squad as Tucci was providing information
as to why police can't be reformed was
the context
where's he at where's he at now by the
way that officer is actually not joking
that woman you can see right away she's
clearly not what are you doing right now
he's not joking she's not even moving
okay listen if you see how I told you
where the weight would be on the back
you couldn't put weight on the neck
commencing I block she's not moving hey
where's your husband at okay here's what
shocked me because I did initially look
at the website I think it's happen in
Bellevue if I'm not mistaken it was a
local police department so I often go to
the local source and try and read the
report myself and it wasn't appropriate
use of force there also but before we
get to it here's actually some video
there is nothing with the entire context
of the video but this one shows you that
she was resisting arrest obviously and
then in the report she reached for the
gearshift and continually reached in her
purse when the police officer said
please stop
he thought she could be reaching for a
weapon and then this video starts where
you can see the resisting arrest occur
long before that video
get on the ground put you out on your
stomach on your stomach
okay so that provides a little bit more
context matters here's something else
that matters that's a video from an
incident that's two years old oh my god
two years old now I know it's tough to
look at but this is important that
officer did not choke that woman and
that's a problem you're gonna have right
now when you say you can't have any
vascular restraints well guess what if
anyone out there anyone out there who
does is grappling you know if you miss
it show for example or anyone who
watches the UFC what you can see is if
you miss a choke and someone doesn't go
out what happens is it turns into a neck
crank yeah you end up either crushing
the jaw or you have to crank the neck
you need to control somebody right you
need to be able to control a perp when
you see that video this is something a
lot of people may not recognize but
there's a position called neon belly if
someone is on their back you are putting
your knee on their belly all of that
weight how we are taught to some classes
this leg should be able to move around
right right all of your weight should be
in the belly if you put that weight on
the neck you couldn't control them they
would immediately slide out it would
hurt for half a second right in that
scenario what you see is a restraint and
you clearly see him pivot around from
her back she's not unconscious he wasn't
choking her he was putting her in that
position to try and control her and then
gets her in a shoulder lock where all
his weight is on her back and this other
leg acts as a block for her arm he
wouldn't be able to pull off that pivot
and maneuver if the weight was on her
neck but everyone's going to be looking
for it now careful what you wish for if
you tell officers they cannot use any
vascular restraints they're probably
going to end up with more joint and neck
injuries and I do think it should be a
last resort but what do you do when
someone by the way you don't get the
call for the sheriff
well you know what maybe he'll be at the
police department or baby he'll be off
on vacation I don't know oh there you go
into the day yeah well and he was it was
being you know like hey do not move do
not move when he had her when he was
restraining her saying hey do not move
because she had been resisting before
because she had been messing around and
reaching in her purse for stuff like
Carlton you see modular slaughter on
police oh yeah it's super common that's
why we met when we were growing up we
didn't have to cut nearly as wide of a
swath of release officers but because
there were record numbers of police
officers being hit they know how to take
certain precautions and none of it is
something that we're happy about it
would be great if no one broke the law
it'll be great right if everyone
understood their constitutional rights
and appropriate interaction with police
officers it would be great if people
waited an hour for evidence it would be
great if Phil on Omar didn't tweet out
two-year-old videos to stoke the flames
of racial hatred but that's not the
world that we live in and so the best
that we can do at this point is get to
the truth and that requires waiting just
a minute hey if you enjoyed this show
subscriber hit the notification to
uncover it's cold in here so I'm
covering covering my nips hit all
notifications on the notification bell
because apparently notification absque
rip shion's don't mean a whole lot look
their video what they're playing in
boxes those happen in court about code
their videos playing in boxes you should
click one of them maybe one of them is a
mystery box cut glass with these things